you
the sounding joy
music
No more lesson
when sorrows grow
no thorns infest the grove
he comes to make his blessings flow
far as the curse is found
far as far as
far as
the curse is found
he rules the world
with truth and grace
and makes the nations prove
the glories of his righteousness
and wonders of his love
and wonders
of his truth
the sounding joy
repeat
say
rejoice
Emmanuel
shall come to thee
Oh Israel
Rejoice
Emmanuel
shall come to thee
Oh Israel
Oh, oh, the night
of our dear Savior's birth
Long lay the world
in sin and error pining
Till He appeared
and the soul felt its worth
A thrill of hope
the weary world rejoices
for yonder breaks
a new and glorious morn
© transcript Emily Beynon
www.youtube.com or www.facebook.com